[Music]
and these are my 10 essentials
[Music]
i always said it's my first essential
schmurder chain i got this on the first
when i got home you're
like 150 right here maserati gave me
this and the homeboys gave me this one
right here yeah i'm saying much about
this right here i got this for a
birthday ring
oh my avioni gave me this 25 right here
i got this one
from eric the jeweler he gave me his ash
and cuts right here very special
um
avioni gave me a bracelet to match the
chain
um
so this jaw only could wear in the strip
clubs though it's called a 8 inch bobby
chain i'm getting
is it aged bobby chad is coming strip
club's old he read it all
this right here hold on
it's my torch i keep it with me come on
[ __ ] be stealing like this [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
don't trust the rest of them bags of
safe sex fire nights extra large safe
sex please
condoms and protection y'all please
you're having sex have safe sex please
no don't be having babies you can't take
it
safe sex please
[Music]
anytime i come off stage i need to fiji
anytime before i go on stage i need to
drink a fiji when i get up in the
morning i drink the fiji you have after
i work out and before i work out i drink
a whole bottle of fiji that's why i'm
always like
don't drink juice straight water
ah now this i'm gonna need this see i
need this because she don't know how to
stop she anytime she won't go outside
she won't go shopping she got these hair
i'll be putting i told her about that
hey i told the girl here last time i'd
be pulling the weave out all the time
and she got me paid for this so i can't
leave without this money and then you
know my nephew think i'm saying this a
little bit right he'd be tripping all
types of [ __ ] yeah i'm saying then i got
listen i can't leave without this money
god
cause when i wake up i pray to god i
ain't gotta lift the k up
[Laughter]
i gotta pray i gotta read 91 and 23
every day now i'm saying every day when
i wake up i gotta read 91-23 my
grandmama said hey day when i wake up
say two [ __ ] body
go [ __ ] read a bible yeah listen uh
that's what she said every day i gotta
read 91 and 23.5 okay
i'm next essential i don't go nowhere
without my bag i need my bag to carry my
[ __ ]
you gotta keep the louis back you
understand got a couple i got a lot of
pockets i got like eight pockets in
there got like two three other pockets
in there i didn't got a pocket in the
back
when did you cop your first movie
um
actually a friend got this for me
a friend got this from me when it came
he gave me like a whole louis set
so i appreciate that and i i i'm highly
immoral so you give me something i'll
still have it for years let's unless i
don't lose it i'm saying
yeah i'm on parole and i got a passport
playing no [ __ ] game and i'm icy
in my passport too tonight i got the
chainsaw
i'll go to jamaica i'm going to africa
i'm going into that
[Music]
all right this phone is for my business
my family my friends
this phone right here is for brandy
legacy
nikki
um selena i think i say you say your
name right celine i keep [ __ ] your
name
[Music]
blistex can lead that thing right there
you guard
run around them as she lifts me down the
lips
white powder
uh yeah i gotta keep that thing i'm
saying run around no ashy lipstick cut
them off right i can't be doing that
keeping my she's too big to be running
my ass here if they got to be nice to ah
you know what what's your name
now i know i ain't got no waves right
right now at this moment but they ain't
trained
yeah i'm staying in the process we're in
the process right now with 360 right now
yeah i'm saying we're the process of
getting this thing together right now
you know i've been running around i
ain't having to do ready for me but
we're in the process of getting this
thing together right now so i got to
keep this with me you know i'm saying
just give give me like three weeks it'll
be together watch 2022 it's going to be
splash you're going to need a whole
bunch of surfboards you're already going
to need this jet ski or type of [ __ ]
yeah
[Music]
this can't smoke without this right yeah
about molly can't smoke without you see
me that's a real thing to simmer
all right guys bobby schmidty to my
tennis central thanks for watching peace
out gang